hangout this is part of big things
lifelong learning channel on YouTube
I'm Jason gots I'm an editor and
curriculum developer here at big Fink
and today we have the pleasure of
talking with Robert Greene the author of
multiple international best-selling
books including the 48 laws of power
his most recent book mastery and his big
think mentor workshop on how to achieve
mastery teach strategies for finding
your life's work and the mentor who can
help you master it welcome Robert thank
you for having me Jason my pleasure
and I would also like to welcome our
mentor members mentor members of our
mentor community
Leah artists coleus and paulius katrakas
so get rickets yes okay sorry
okay so I'd like to begin with with Leah
she had some questions for Robert about
about the videos on mental and well
first of all thanks guys for hosting
this this is super awesome I've been a
fan of yours for quite some time Robert
so it's great to be able to dive into
your most recent work with you via be
think big thing so thank you Jason as
well the first question I kind of want
to kick off with starts really at the
beginning of the process right it's
figuring out your passion and you speak
to really tapping into whatever you were
passionate as a child yes and I I think
it's interesting because when you're an
adult I think it's almost hard to
remember who you were as a child
depending on you know what you
gravitated towards or whatever so I
wanted to see if there were any other
indicators as an adult say that if you
can't remember what your initial
passions were that can help you figure
out what you should be you know really
exploring for what you want to master
well it's a great question the thing is
it's always really important to be able
to tap in to your childhood even if it
seems difficult the problem
have nowadays were so instant oriented
that the idea that it could take a few
weeks or months of using a journal or a
therapist or talking with someone just
seems outrageous like I have to know
this instantly who I was when I was six
years older this inclination but it's a
process and it's a it's a hugely
important process because as you move
through life you constantly need to
return to that sense of who you are so
you can judge ok this crisis that I'm
facing is it really important does it
really enjoy I am do I need to take this
sort of possible crap job or this job
that offers a lot of money but is it
necessarily Who I am knowing who you are
is is such an important skill in life
nobody really talks about it like a
skill so I would not try to bypass that
process of going into your childhood
figuring out who you are when I do
consulting with people now and then
doing a little bit less of it these days
I we spend several days weeks trying to
go back and remember certain things that
there's traces there it's not completely
buried but then there are also signs of
stuff in the present so they're gonna be
subjects and activities that still
elicit that kind of childlike excitement
in you if you don't experiencing that
with any subject then that's best kind
of sad or a little bit of trouble you
know nobody know there are people like
that but it's there's still gonna be
things where you open the newspaper you
get online people bring up a
conversation and your eyes light up and
you want to hear about it you want to
read about it I know for instance for me
it's there's certain subjects that
really get me going and particularly
about early humans when I look at the
newspaper I see an article like that
there's gonna be something for that the
same for you also you want to look at
things that you hate that repulse you
that about the world or a job that you
really dislike do you want to think
about what is it that I disliked about
it you want to get in touch
who you are that's why I'm telling you
to go into the childhood thing because
who you are
a lot of the time is a reflect you think
you know it but it's actually a
reflection of what other people have
told you your parents your friends you
don't really know who you are but when
you were young when you were six seven
eight years old the fact that you were
naturally drawn to music to sound to
dancing to physical activity its before
anybody infected you with their ideas of
about who you should be and that's why
it's so important to go back into that
process awesome thanks you will okay um
Leah did you have other questions that
you wanna ask Robert I thought we would
just continue through each person's
questions and then add yeah absolutely
so I think there's an interesting trend
especially in America and it happening
with the way the workforce is shifting
especially kind of in the younger
generations with more people gravitating
towards entrepreneurship I think that
might almost be a rejection perhaps of
so to speak of those jobs that people
don't necessarily love to be in as we
were just kind of speaking to but I
think there's an interesting thought the
kind of mastery your work most racially
done especially the book that's
potentially a strong Genesis for debate
and and the question is do you think
that everyone is truly destined for
mastery you know because there's you
just jump in yeah well I've been
addressed that question a talk recently
because a lot of journalists will ask me
that and when they ask me that there's a
hint in there that maybe I'm being
cynical that I really don't believe it
that maybe I'm just doing it to sell
books but I really actually sincerely
believe it
I believe very deeply that's not a
belief it's a fact that everybody is
born with that uniqueness that I talk
about in the book it's a biological
neurological fact and it gets obscured
over the years as you start listening to
other people and you go through this
alienating
but deep down inside there's something
extremely unique about you there's a
famous psychologist from the 60s he's
not so popular anymore named Abraham
Maslow and he had a pyramid of values
and he maintained that the ultimate
value for a human being is to feel that
they're fulfilling themselves like
they're they have creative potential and
that they're able to realize that
potential so Who am I or who is anybody
else to say that not that there are only
some people who are destined for mastery
you can't go inside their heads you
can't see who they are there's the great
example in the book I have I loved of
Martha Graham who was one of the
greatest masters of all time I started a
whole new genre of dance and she said
you should never ever tell somebody that
they're not talented talent is is
completely irrelevant factor for success
in life it's how much you love what
you're doing and how much energy you put
into it and then the talent will come
you have you have natural gifts that can
be developed so she's saying that I
think she said it because when she was
younger people were putting her down and
thought that she had no potential as a
dancer and here she became one of the
greatest dancers ever I think it's
ridiculous for anybody to be able to say
Oh only a few people these people here
they're the ones destined for mastery
and I deliberately chose Temple Grandin
to profile in mastery if for those who
don't know her she's woman born with
autism who basically at the age of two
or three was going to be hospitalized
for the rest of her life she couldn't
learn language etc and she be she has
become an incredible scientist on animal
behavior and on the subject of autism
itself if someone born with autism
become become can become a master that I
think we can say everybody is destined
for awesome yeah the the point I was
going to make from a lot of the pushback
perhaps that even journalists give you
is if you look at societal roles right
we're governments and economic systems
and whatnot are structured you know
everybody can be a master in their own
way but we need people to to help do the
jobs that aren't necessarily glamorous
and take a lot of love and time and
insight so I think that's largely what's
also interesting two things yes
technology's replacing a lot of those
extremely unglamorous jobs so that's
good some of that's bad but then you're
gonna say oh this person growing up in
this bad neighborhood should be one of
those people doing those terrible jobs
why can't you say that everybody should
explore this process there will always
be people in a culture who don't want to
go through the process for whatever
reason they don't feel that Drive they
don't feel the need for it or they want
a comfortable paycheck there will always
be people who do that I just don't want
to be the one to say you know this who
you are you know that's your own
personal choice yeah absolutely
a bit of a personal question for you is
you know your your journey as an author
and and kind of along those subject
lines that you've really pursued have
been known for started from your own
kind of rejection of corporate roles or
you know the alienating work world where
do you or what do you think that you
have mastered along the way or where do
you think you've tapped into you know
who you are meant to be and what do you
think that is besides an author well if
I didn't I gave a talk recently a TED
talk in London a couple weeks ago it'll
be online soon and I explained I don't
usually talk about myself and that in
that
Way but I explained my own weird journey
where basically up to the age of 36
I had nothing really I had tried 50
different jobs more than that actually
but the point of my story that I told to
the Ted audience was during those years
the wandering trying all different jobs
journalism Hollywood construction work
working in a hotel teaching English etc
I kept writing I kept searching I kept
saying I want to try this it didn't work
all right I'll write a novel that didn't
work I'm gonna write a play that didn't
work I tried jobs where I would have
weird experiences in life I worked in a
detective agency and that gave me ideas
about people but didn't lead to the
novel I thought it would lead to and
then when I got the opportunity to write
a book
suddenly everything that I had done in
the past now had value so all of those
terrible crap jobs that I had done in my
life had exposed me to so many different
kinds of people in so many different
cultures that I had a I think an
understanding of psychology that I
wouldn't have had if I just spent my
whole life working at Time magazine all
of the research that I had done for
television Hollywood had taught me how
to find stories and in libraries that I
could use for the book all of my reading
of history gave me the storehouse of
stories I could use for the 48 laws of
power so I can I can't say that I've
mastered anything besides writing but
the fact that I love writing and I never
gave up and I tried 10 different ways of
approaching it gave me all of these
different skills that I could use to
write a book and I tell people I'm not
trying to use myself as a paradigm but I
tell people that that's sort of what the
where the future lies you you try
different things out knowing more or
less who you are and what you want to
explore and in doing that and listening
to who you are and saying I don't like
this I do like that you're gonna
a series of five or six or seven real
important skills that you'll be able to
combine in a business in an art form in
science that will make you you know a
master they'll make you have a unique
set of skills that will make you
irreplaceable you won't be that person
who's 38 years old who will then be
downsized because they can get rid of
you and replace you with someone cheaper
and younger you have something extremely
unique and creative and you can't be
replaced so I don't remember your
question I hope I answered absolutely
okay okay and that that that that was
wonderful and I um I think at this point
we'll move on to Polly aces questions
just in the interest of time okay so
okay and and really interesting response
you know I found it you know much
similar in my own path for example so I
was wondering in the workshop you talked
a lot about finding a niche you know a
place you know where you can become you
know a master of it so I wanted to know
for example how do you find such a niche
you know when do you know that it's time
to move on to another one
are there any indications that it's
going well or that it's you know that's
not going well or something like that
well every person is different and and
and it's more of a feeling that's why I
talked about sort of getting in touch
with yourself I know it sounds kind of a
new-agey but it's actually really
important so I know for instance I was
working in journalism for three or four
years that's probably the longest I ever
tried my at one particular job and I
just didn't feel right I felt like I was
writing articles and I liked writing but
they were only people would read it for
a week and then it disappeared and the
impermanence of it bugged me I wanted to
write something that people would read
for for weeks or months or years and
that feeling meant I had to look to the
future and say can I do this for the
next five or ten years that's this kind
of process you have to go through can
you see can you imagine yourself work
at this very narrow position all the way
until the future you want to have like
possibilities possibilities of the
greatest thing in life so by the time
that man I met that man who offered me
the idea of the possibility of writing a
book I now had all of this experience
that I could create something
interesting you want to have that
possibility if an opportunity comes to
you in this direction over here over
here that you can take it and you have
skills to to exploit it if you stay at
that one little funnel job for three
four or five six years you're not gonna
have that richness of possibilities as
you get older you're not going to be 25
or 26 your whole life so you're gonna be
40 at some point anyway maybe think
ahead how will I feel at 40 still doing
this job as a writer on a very narrow
field those are kind of the thoughts
that you go through as well as there's a
difference there are people out there
who are just seer who are just Restless
and nothing satisfies them so every six
months they feel compelled to try
something new that's a problem that's a
psychological problem I'm not talking
about changing jobs just for the sake of
it it has to be come from somewhere deep
where you know that you meant to do
something interesting and this isn't it
as opposed to I'm bored let's try
something new so there's a difference
there I hope you can see what I'm
talking about
right right the key is if having a sense
of self-awareness to know that this is a
position that's just not suited to me as
opposed to I'm just somebody that can't
devote my energy to one particular thing
but I have a lot of stories in the book
of people like myself who wandered
through life like Paul Graham like Yuki
Matsuoka
they try different things and they see
or even Ramachandra on the
neuroscientist and they see this isn't
working but suddenly an opportunity
comes to them where they realize oh this
is a direct
I should head in that seems really
promising and the difference between the
master and someone who isn't is they're
willing to experiment and try this new
direction and see if it works
so truely sounds like the advice is to
make sure that something on resonates
from within yourself and to be willing
to explore to have an adventurous spirit
so a lot of people are so addicted to
the paycheck that they have an
opportunity comes to try something
different in an Avenue that's more
entrepreneurial or it's a little bit
more of a risk and they won't take it
because they're afraid so it's a matter
of knowing who you are and being a
little bit bold when you're younger you
can afford to be bolder because you
don't necessarily have a family to
support and all these other things going
on so I'm really advocating having a
kind of an adventure an adventurous
spirit and to try different things and
to see what resonates with you and what
doesn't yeah I mean if you never try
you'll never discover and then and then
my second question was you know we were
talking about the whole you know road to
mastery but then once you achieve
mastery
I was curious are there any
physiological changes you know happening
in the body maybe in the brain because
we we've heard a lot about rewiring for
example and things like these no no well
I'm not a see the fame with the 10,000
hour study which is brilliant is that
they could demonstrate statistically a
change in behavior at 10,000 hours now
that's not based on anything where you
could go inside to the brain and
literally map the brain and seeing the
change because we haven't got to that
point yet it was just based on an on the
on the evidence of how many people at
10,000 hours reached this higher level
now subsequently people have gone back
and theorized what happens to the brain
after all of those hours of practice I'm
saying at 20,000 hours imagine what
happens to the brain at 20,000 hours
which is a level that Einstein reached
by the time he came to his theory of
relativity or Glenn Gould reached by the
age in his 20s after he'd been playing
the piano for so many years or Mozart
are all these different
people I can't I don't have a study it
would be a hard study to do because the
number of people who reach that level of
20,000 hours there's not a huge number
but I'm speculating that something does
happen to the brain and I described in
Chapter six what I think happens to the
brain at that point there you look at
like a chess master like a Bobby Fischer
or I have the boxing trainer Freddie
Roach you've internalized so many moves
there are so many different patterns in
the boxing ring you've seen so much that
you've internalized the game itself and
you're now like feeling it it's like at
your fingertips you have an instant in
real-time you're sort of seeing the
holes the dynamic of the game itself
or the battle or the warfare or whatever
it is and it's because so many parts of
the brain have become interconnected
that you no longer have to think about
something it's there in an instant I
have no study to prove it the proof is
the power that certain people in history
have demonstrated when they reach that
twenty thousand and say even thirty
thousand our point yeah it becomes like
second nature basically yeah sorry great
um go ahead oh sorry I wanted to so
there were two other mentor subscribers
who wanted to join this conversation and
for technical reasons weren't able to I
think I'll ask just one question from
each yeah okay so Brett Carney wondered
can you achieve mastery in more than one
field or did you encounter examples of
people you know who did that or is that
simply at odds with the concept of
mastery as you you know no definitely
you can achieve mastery in more than one
field it's what would be interesting to
say is could a musician also master
baseball I mean
take two things that are totally
disconnected I I don't have an example
offhand of something like that which
would be pretty remarkable normally what
you see are people mastering two fields
that are somewhat related a great
example from the book is Paul Graham who
has a company Y Combinator in Silicon
Valley
it's basically an incubator system for
training people how to create a tech
startup and Paul gets a percentage if
there's if their idea turns into a
business he gets a percentage of it and
now he's fabulously wealthy because
they've been it's been a hugely
successful system well Paul started off
as a computer programmer
he was an absolute master of programming
he was a hacker
very early on in life and because of his
programming skills he became he started
what became the first via web which was
the first online store placed an
application for starting a business
online
it was huge in 1995 he made fifteen
million dollars on that one thing
because he was so brilliant at Computer
Engineering he got bored with it and he
went to writing and you decided to write
essays really incredible essays that
built up a huge following for him essays
about wealth about entrepreneurship
about philosophy and art etc and then
finally he fell into this thing called Y
Combinator where people kept saying well
you're so good at starting this one
business can you help us start a
business and so he decided to create
this thing called Y Combinator based on
the computer model which is the more
times you try I'm giving a really bad
definition of it but the more times you
try something the greater your chances
of finding success at finding the right
path so his model was to bring in not
just as an angel investor 10 people a
year like most people do he would try
and invest in 300 he would bring in 3 or
4 or 500 young people every year in his
system and through doing this with so
many different people he would gain an
intense
city of knowledge that would make him a
master of figuring out what is a solid
technology idea in three or four years
so he's a master at business and
entrepreneurship at computer engineering
perhaps writing I don't know but they're
all kind of related he took the model of
computer engineering and hacking and
applied it to business and
entrepreneurship there are many other
examples but what I would be curious and
to answered this person's question would
be to find somebody who has mastered two
things the the Howard Gardner has this
book on the five frames of intelligence
there's their spatial mechanical kinetic
etc to find somebody who has
intelligence in different frames
different types of intelligence mass
that would be an incredible thing maybe
like a DaVinci would be the one that
would come closest to it as someone
who's a great artist and is also a great
scientist I don't know maybe something
like that and yeah I'm thinking of the
people we tend to we call polymaths
and Dave yeah David Foster Wallace the
late David as well as popped into my
mind as somebody who is a pretty
advanced tennis player and then also
really a writer and also a fairly
accomplished mathematician I believe I
don't know whether it would own his
mastery in all I bow to you I'm just a
fanboy of David Foster Wallace that's
why he's amazing I didn't know about the
tennis I mean you're right somebody like
the Benjamin Franklin polymath so a
great thing with Benjamin Franklin is it
the ger if a rider but he was also a
great scientist he was also a great
politician so yeah there you go
thank you David husband was also wanting
to join us and he asks how do you have
any suggestions for how a young
apprentice can best approach a potential
mentor or maybe examples from the book
how an apprentice can break the ice with
a mentor who is popular intimidating
somewhat inaccessible well
what I say in the book is mentors aren't
as inaccessible as you might think they
have a weak spot generally if you're
really high up in your field there's a
loneliness factor where you don't have
as many peers and friends and people
that you can trust and that you can
interact with so first of all you should
never think that there's intimidating as
they appear because they're not and they
do everybody most everybody finds the
idea of having a mentor of having a
mentee as something potentially deeply
satisfying so you shouldn't be
intimidated or you should be less
intimidated than you imagine the second
thing is people aren't going to just
become your mentor because they love you
or because you could looking or you've
got a friendly manner they're going to
hi go into that relationship because you
have something to offer now granted
being a charming can help etc but you
have real skills so I tell people don't
start searching for that important
mentor until you have something you feel
like you can offer because you're gonna
that you're gonna be really intimidated
when you try and talk to them because
you know deep down inside you're not
ready for this position so I have in the
book the greatest story of them all is
is Michael Faraday the experimental
scientist of the 19th century and how he
got Humphrey Davy to become his mentor
which basically made his career he could
spend eight years teaching himself
everything about science to the point
where he was so prepared and Humphrey
Davy could recognize it that he can now
serve as a really valuable mentee or
protege so be prepared be ready don't if
you if you have your eyes set on this
person they were ready to take a year or
two developing the kind of skills that
will interest them in using you the
third thing is you want to choose a
mentor for the right reasons
so just because someone is popular or
famous or has a lot of followers on
Twitter that doesn't make
the best choice for you as a mentor the
the it's almost like you're choosing
your second parent and you're not going
to choose a parent just because they're
there liked or popular or famous it has
to be an emotional fit the mentor
relationship is an emotional
relationship they see you almost as the
child of a son or daughter they never
had you see them as a parent figure that
maybe you never had because of that
emotional connection you open yourself
up to their instruction and they open
themselves up to sharing their secrets
with you so you want to make a choice
based on someone who has the right
spirit for instance in five or ten years
I would like to be like that person I
would like to have that kind of skills
that it's not I want to be that popular
I want to be that famous it's I want to
be doing their kind of work that's the
key there so sometimes you make the
wrong choice just because that person
who may not be so famous who in the same
field but has an interesting set of
skills that match what you're thinking
of that's the better mentor and I have
in the book the example of yoky Matsuoka
who chose Rodney Brooks as her mentor at
MIT at the robotics lab because he was a
rebel and she's a rebel and she wanted
she liked his anti-authoritarian
attitude and she could identify with it
so here she found the perfect
anti-authoritarian mentor to to teach
her that's the kind of thing you're
looking at so those would be the three
main points I would I would tell them
great mmm so so we're coming to the end
of our time here um I I want to thank
Leah for joining us and paulius and
given extra special thanks to Robert
Green for being with us today um thank
you thank you guys yeah and and to the
audience out there you've been watching
a big think mentor at Google hangout
with Robert Greene he's the author of
mastery and you can visit youtube.com
slash user slash big think mentor one
word to take
or to view robert's popular video
workshop on how to achieve mastery in
your life and work thank you so much
everyone for being with us today thank
you - Thank You Liam Thank You paulius
great question thanks about very welcome